ce mardi 21 février c'est une nouvelle
page qui se tourne pour la médiathèque
des 7 Mares d'Élancourt après 9 mois de
fermeture pour différents travaux de
rénovation thermique et de réaménagement
c'est le grand jour pour accueillir les
visiteurs nous avons profité des travaux
pour procéder à un réaménagement des
espaces publics donc par exemple on a
maintenant un espace pour les ados ce
que nous n'avons pas avant on a laissé
plus de place à certaines collections
comme les collections de mangas par
exemple on a des espaces d'accueil qui
sont plus conviviaux on a changé les
flux de circulation des publics pour le
prêt le retour de nouveaux espaces et
une réouverture qui ravie les habitués
pour certains fidèles depuis plusieurs
années et dont le centre culturel
commençait à manquer après les retards
c'était un peu à mort dans l'âme qu'on
attendait mais enfin ça vient de rouvrir
quand on a l'objet physique matériel en
face de soi on est plus on est plus
curieux de de découvrir que si c'est
juste un lien sur YouTube un sentiment
que partage cette habitude depuis plus
de 15 ans venue chercher cette fois-ci
des DVD alors j'ai pris un film alors je
crois qu'il est je sais j'ai un film
nordique j'ai oublié le régime de
réalisateur
qui s'appelle Oli maki et puis un film
français elle a fait une fleur au-delà
de la variété des collections depuis sa
création en 1976 c'est la convivialité
qui est appréciée ohlala moi je me suis
inscrite avec mes enfants quand ils
étaient en CM2 elle a presque 38 39 ans
alors je ça fait des années qu'on vient
donc on a connu la première bibliothèque
le renouveau etc les travaux et puis là
bah on est content de revenir en plus on
a plein de petits gâteaux du café c'est
génial faut venir deux journées sont
prévues pour fêter la réouverture le
mercredi 15 mars et le samedi 18 mars
différentes animations des ateliers une
scène ouverte et même un concert seront
organisés avec ce rafraîchissement c'est
un nouveau chapitre qui s'ouvre pour la
médiathèque